Ron DeSantis now down barely to 20
percent on average in recent polling he
had reached as high as 32-33 and Donald
Trump continues to climb now holding 55
percent of the Republican primary ballot
uh understanding also that a bunch of
the support is among people who aren't
even running at this point in time Mike
Pence has nearly six percent but he's
not running at least not right now Tim
Scott has two percent has not yet
announced the candidacy Larry Elder has
a one point Chris Christie has one point
Christy may run Hutchinson just shy of
one point
uh and sununu seven tenths of a point so
what does this mean well this means that
unless Ron DeSantis can take support
from people currently supporting the
failed former president Donald Trump he
has no path to the nomination